Now that I'm by the river, I
can catch some fish for dinner.
I don't have a hook
or line with me.
But the Raramuri know
how to get everything
they need from the plants.
I can get my fishing
line from an agave.
You can take these spikes.
Careful not to go right
through your tongue.
Size per size, this is way, way
stronger than cotton thread.
I can take this--
if I put a little bit
of a twist into it,
it'll make it about
four times stronger.
I can't break it.
It's amazing how strong it is.
For hooks, the Raramuri
use another plant--
a black tipped agave.
What I'm after are these
really hard, woody barbs.
Here we go.
The ground near the river
is crawling with insects,
so I have lots of bait.
And my line's in for just a
few minutes when I get a bite.
Just a little catfish there.
Doesn't really matter if it's
a big one or a small one.
All fish are protein.